[Música]
este domingo los brasileños van a las
urnas en unas elecciones generales con
ingredientes que le dan un toque muy
interesante a estos comicios hay un
inédito clima de tensión en parte por
esas dudas que ha generado el presidente
y también aspirante a la reelección Yair
bolsonaro sobre si reconocerá o no una
posible derrota en las urnas bolsonaro
también ha puesto en duda el desempeño
del sistema electoral el mismo sistema
que lo eligió a él como presidente que
lo llevó al palacio de plan alto hace
algunos años atrás veamos algunos datos
importantes son elecciones generales el
voto es obligatorio en Brasil cerca de
156 millones de ciudadanos están
llamados a las urnas se trata de El
padrón electoral más grande de la
historia de Brasil van a elegir al
presidente al vicepresidente y también a
los gobernadores de cada uno de los
estados también van a elegir un tercio
de los 81 integrantes del senado y los
otros dos tercios ya fueron elegidos en
el año 2018 simplemente van a completar
el resto del senado también para elegir
a los 513 integrantes de la cámara de
diputados y a la totalidad de los
integrantes de las asambleas
legislativas estatales y de la cámara
legislativa del distrito federal vamos a
hacer énfasis entonces en las elecciones
presidenciales son 11 candidatos en
total los dos con más opciones para
pasar a una segunda vuelta o para llegar
al triunfo son el actual presidente Yair
bolsonaro quien aspira a un nuevo
mandato se trata de un ex militar líder
de la derecha en ese país y se enfrenta
a Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva uno de los
políticos tal vez más reconocidos del
país suramericano en los últimos años ya
gobernó Brasil en el pasado en el año
2003 y en el año 2010 de triunfar en las
urnas sería su tercer mandato como
presidente varias preguntas sobre la
mesa Entonces cómo llega Brasil a este
escenario electoral Cuáles son las
coyunturas que hay en este país en este
momento
una amplia polarización que se ha hecho
incluso eco en la misma campaña
presidencial tanto bolsonaro como Lula
han hecho
énfasis en sus experiencias como
políticos pero han bombardeado
constantemente a sus adversarios a
través de los discursos y las
intervenciones que hacen en los medios
de comunicación en estas elecciones
según los analistas va a ser crucial el
voto de los jóvenes y también de los
evangélicos y temas como la recuperación
económica el medio ambiente la amazonía
la seguridad en el país y también ese
reposicionamiento de Brasil a nivel
internacional son algunos de los temas
de importancia para estas elecciones
pero son justamente las amenazas del
presidente bolsonaro de no reconocer
estos resultados que y que no sean a
favor de él estos resultados lo que
genera pues cierto temor de un posible
golpe algunos analistas no han podido
llamar así o de un escenario que se
parezca como al de Estados Unidos en
donde recorde Cómo fue en todos los
hechos que hubo después de las
elecciones cuando Donald Trump resultó
Derrotado allí y pues vemos que ahora en
la presidencia está el presidente Joe
biden la pregunta que queda sobre la
mesa y tal vez punto central de este
debate es si la democracia brasileña
está en peligro lo vamos a analizar en
unos minutos para conversar sobre este
tema saludamos a Paulo moura él es
periodista y cientista político él se
encuentra en la ciudad de San Pablo y
desde Río de Janeiro se conecta también
Pablo Velasco él es profesor de política
Internacional de la Universidad del
estado de Río de Janeiro a nuestros
televidentes les recuerdo que también
hacen parte de esta conversación pueden
dejar todas sus preguntas los
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales ya lo saben estamos en Twitter
en instagram en Facebook allí no se
encuentran como arroba
france24_es@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f24 pueden ver la señal en
streaming a través de nuestro canal de
YouTube y también te recuerdo que todos
los contenidos del debate ya se
encuentran disponibles en podcast nos
pueden oír en diferentes plataformas
estamos en Apple podcast en Spotify
deezer y tuning
Bueno pues le doy la bienvenida en esta
ocasión tenemos a dos paulos invitados a
el programa comienzo con Pablo moura en
la ciudad de Sao Paulo y El Punto de
partida para entender el contexto para
quienes estamos fuera de las fronteras
brasileñas Paulo es entender cómo es el
panorama general de Brasil cómo llega el
país a estas elecciones presidenciales
bueno bueno para explicar la situación
Brasil es necesario volver a 2013
cuando el pueblo no se ayuda a las
calles con saturación de los gobiernos
fetistas una situación de dispersión
millones de personas sin rumbos sin
partidos sin dirección
impulsada por las redes sociales
salieron a la calle este proceso después
de la elección de 2014
un dificuse en contra el gobierno Dilma
de PT y la movilización jamás ha cesaba
ha cambiado de
intensidad pero en
2015-2016 le llevó la al impeachman de
la presidente Vilma en 2018
a la elección del presidente postrado
Entonces es un cambio estructural de la
sociedad brasilera de la política
brasilera la base social
del presidente bolsonaro es de gente de
la iniciativa privada
emprendedor en todos los tipos pequeños
autónomos medios grandes el lagro
negocio predominantemente gente que
trabajaría produce la riqueza de Brasil
genera empleos
y que se ha levantado en contra el otro
Brasil que es el Brasil es siempre el
Brasil patrimonialista que es común en
América Latina Brasil es un
emprendimiento Estatal el estado
brasileño ha nacido antes de la nación
históricamente es gobernado el poder es
detenido por una por un estamento
Aliado de la elitis del funcionalismo
público de los de la parcela corrupta
del sistema político de empresarios que
gravitan en tu entorno del Estado sí
sudando los cofres cools Este es el
plano de fondo del conflicto y llegamos
sí Entonces el presidente pulsonal está
enfrentando estas fuerzas las grandes
corporaciones de mí y a grandes empresas
los bancos gente con interés
internacionales en Brasil claro
Lula es simplemente el candidato de esta
gente
partes de este panorama lo completamos
ahora con Pablo Velasco en la ciudad de
Río de Janeiro Pablo también bebindo
gracias por acompañarnos y completemos
este panorama qué perspectiva tiene
usted de cómo llega a Brasil a estos
comicios presidenciales
Hola Santiago encantado en hablar con
ustedes Bueno pues Brasil llegan una
situación
muy complicada un país absolutamente
dividido una asociación política
extremadamente
preocupante la polarización en efecto
empezó hace como 10 años ahí por el 2013
en las llamadas jornadas de junio en a
lo que se refería el otro Pablo cuando
la gente salió a las calles pero en ese
tiempo Brasil vivió una situación
económica muy grave una verdadera
debacle económica en una verdadera de
cada perdida podemos decir cuando los
indicadores sociales empeoraron
muchísimo en el país hubo un avance muy
preocupante en la pobreza en el número
de personas con hambre en el país
entonces todo esto claro agrava una
situación política que ya venía muy
complicada y la pandemia obviamente pues
lo empeoró todo aún más es decir
llegamos a una situación incluso de
violencia política
hay que recordar que hace cuatro años el
propio presidente bolsonaro sufrió un
atentado y ya ha habido algunos casos
recientes de apoyadores o del PT o de
Bolsón ahora que también han sufrido
violencia política han sido incluso
asesinados es decir una asociación muy
grave muy triste para Brasil una
división brutal violenta y un país que
en términos sociales económicos va muy
muy mal eso para no citar claro algunas
posiciones del actual presidente que
ponen en riesgo la democracia y las
instituciones en el país lo que ha hecho
el presidente bolsonaro es sembrar dudas
sembrar muchas dudas sobre las urnas
electrónicas el voto electrónico de
alguna manera queriendo decir que puede
no reconocer el resto de electoral lo
que naturalmente es algo muy grave para
un país que se pretende democrático como
Brasil hace ya más de 30 años creo que
para terminar de ver el panorama general
de este momento electoral que está Vivi
Brasil me parece importante voy a hacer
la ronda la inversa continuó con Pablo
Velasco ver cómo han sido las campañas
hemos visto acusaciones pocas propuestas
por parte de los candidatos en términos
generales entre los 11 candidatos y
incluso los mismos candidatos fomentando
esa División y esa polarización que hay
en la sociedad brasileña que otro
balance o análisis puede hacer usted de
del desempeño de las campañas
han sido campañas muy pobres en efecto
campañas muy pobres donde las
estrategias y efectivamente Cuáles son
los planes para el futuro pues no han
quedado nada claros no se sabe muy bien
Por ejemplo de qué es lo que pretende
hacer el candidato anulado Silva en
términos económicos se limita en gran
medida a decir que él sabe cómo hacerlo
porque ya ha sido presidente durante dos
mandatos y lo hizo muy bien en los años
2000 efectivamente Brasil creció mucho
en aquel periodo y he mejorado muchísimo
en términos sociales también por
seguridad del candidato Yair bolsonaro
Pues básicamente ha intentado conquistar
algunos segmentos
brasileños a través de una serie de
auxilios El auxilio Brasil por ejemplo
en el que se garantiza a la población
con renta más baja una serie de
beneficios también algunos grupos
económicos como los taxistas los
conductores de camiones ha disminuido
los impuestos sobre los combustibles
disminuye el precio del gas una serie de
ventajas económicas que han intentado
seducir a la población pero por lo menos
según lo que dicen las encuestas y los
sondeos más recientes no han tenido
mucho efecto porque prácticamente no ha
conseguido subir en términos
precentuales el candidato Yair bolsonaro
y Lula mantiene una ventaja muy muy
importante claro eso desde que Confiemos
en los sondeos ahí los demás candidatos
Pues tampoco se han limitado en gran
medida a deslegitimar a lurea bolsonaron
se presentan como una tercera vía a
diferentes del ulebolsonal ahora
intentan de alguna manera decir que
Brasil tiene que evitar la polarización
no votando por ninguno de los dos y
votando por estos otros candidatos pero
que nunca han conseguido despegar en
términos electorales nunca han tenido un
apoyo importante según los sondeos ya
veremos cuál van a ser esos resultados y
qué tan cierto su aproximados eran los
sondeos le doy la palabra ahora a Pablo
en moura sobre las candidaturas las
campañas qué evaluación y análisis hace
usted ya Pablo Velasco nos daba desde el
punto de vista cuál es el suyo
bueno la
publicidad la política es es
simplificación no la propaganda requiere
esto mensajes cortas simples e
impactantes y esto simplifica el debate
pero a mí me parece que el debate está
claro que las posiciones
en hecho Lula no ha recogido su programa
de gobierno alegando que tiene que hacer
una amplia frente para para vencer la
elección no se sabe lo que vas a hacer
pero al empezar la campaña y le ha dicho
que iba a romper con con los fundamentos
económicos con la ética fiscal y otras
medidas rever privatizaciones
aumentar los los impuestos del sector
del agro negocio y todo esto pero al
revés bolsonaro tiene un programa Claro
que es el programa que están dando un
programa liberal conservador quiere
responsable de la situación económica
excepcional que vive Brasil en
comparación con el mundo
necesario decir que los analistas
políticos en la prensa y nos dan listas
económicos todos han errado las
proyecciones sobre la economía brasilera
antes durante y después de la pandemia
Graciela el país que tuvo unos dos
millones económicos y sanitarios en la
pandemia incluso vacunación de la
población y
sorprendió con el crecimiento del pib y
cuatro y medio por ciento en 2021 ahora
está creciendo tres y al empezar del año
los economistas perdieron recesión a
Brasil ministro y economía no se cansa
de decir que ellos iban arar y están
errando
todos están errando de economía
brasileña está general de empleos está
con queda de inflación está con
desempeño excepcional la Revolución en
La infraestructura que ha hecho el
presidente bolsonaro promete crecimiento
regular por 10 años a Brasil con
contratos firmados Esto no es promesa
electoral Son acuerdos reformas
constitucionales que cambiaron la
legislación sobre concesiones
privatizaciones de
infraestructuras estatales es un
programa liberal económico claro no hay
dudas lo que será hecho que es
continuidad lo que está haciendo hecho
sobre las encuestas sobre las encuestas
Hay un problema graves grave siempre Fue
grave pero en esta elección está
ocurriendo una cosa excepcional claro
Hay una profusión de encuestas que
inimaginable y las inconsistencias de
las metodologías y de las muestras
empezar a hacer analizadas por
especialistas de lo que se está viendo
es una barbaridad es una escollen los
seguimientos socioeconómicos la
composición de las aguas nuestras como
quieren de signo los lugares de
entrevista como quieren de manera que
hay pez quizás encuestas mostrando
bolsonaro a frente bolsonaro un poco
atrás funcionaron mucho atrás no le
ganeando en primer lugar entonces Claro
[Música]
que hacer investigados por el Congreso
Nacional porque inducir lo que opinión
pública con esto es crimen electoral Sí
ya veremos qué tan cerca o qué tan cerca
o aproximadas estaban estas encuestas
los sabremos a partir de el domingo
señor Maura continuó con usted usted
menciona que la posición y el debate
está claro por lo menos en el tema a
nivel de los candidatos pero que hay al
nivel de los ciudadanos
Tal parece que Brasil no es ajeno a este
fenómeno que se presenta en otros países
de América Latina en donde los
candidatos y los gobernantes están un
poco desconectados de la realidad de los
ciudadanos y en un país con tantos
problemas sociales y con tantas
divisiones como Brasil Es normal que ese
tipo de elecciones pues se puedan
presentar Cuáles son esos temas que
conversan los brasileños en la calle de
qué debaten los brasileños en cuanto a
las prioridades que debe tener el nuevo
gobierno que llegue ya sea una
continuidad de bolsonaro o que llegue
nuevamente el lugar a Silva de qué
conversan los brasileños qué es lo que
les preocupa de verdad Bueno hay una
disonancia cognitiva entre las campañas
del pueblo las demandas por lo que dicen
las encuestas esta de las cuales te
confío pero en esto hace fundamento es
salud seguridad empleo el debate fue
fuertemente centrado en la cuestión
económica debido al problema de los
precios de los combustibles Entonces el
presidente por sonar consiguió aprobar
en el parlamento una reducción de los
impuestos
estaduales de combustible esto provocó
una queda continua acentuada coincidió
con la situación nueva de Mercado de
queda internacional el precio de los
combustibles y con base en otras medidas
liberales los precios de los alimentos y
todo venden caído la inflación brasilera
todavía es alta pero está en una de las
menores de los principales economías del
mundo y la tendencia que es el tiempo y
el avanzar del tiempo favorece al
presidente consonada en este debate
económico nula por su turno
apuesta en la red en los recuerdos en la
memoria del tiempo en que gobernó cuando
hay edad Un gobierno con la situación
fiscal equilibrada y el Petén 8 años
digo gobierno ha destruido la economía
brasilera la destrucción empezó en
gobernar Lula pero aconteció en gobernar
Dilma y en la población no hace conexión
entre lo que empezó en gobiernos
entonces
en esta memoria franca de los brasileños
prometiendo
tratará de vuelta a la prosperidad del
pasado y él por ejemplo sonar lucha para
convencer los brasileros que la
prosperidad está aconteciendo y tiene el
entorno puede abrir mano sí del trabajo
que he hecho el que está comenzando Y
quién debe continuar esta Ese es el
núcleo central del debate pero en la
propaganda no es exactamente así que la
consecuencia debate aborto claro
Cuál es su opinión qué piensa usted al
respecto de esto que dice el Señor moura
y sobre lo que debaten los brasileños y
lo que es una verdadera necesidad para
ellos
Bueno sí yo yo veo que la no hay una
conexión muy muy efectiva entre lo que
el pueblo espera lo que el pueblo quiere
y lo que los políticos han ofrecido en
los últimos años yo creo que los
brasileños siguen sintiéndose muy mal
representados por los gobernantes y creo
que eso está afectando Incluso el apoyo
al gobierno bolsonaro a mucha gente que
votó por él en 2018 pues simplemente no
lo va a hacer otra vez porque no
reconocen este Progreso todo Que mi
colega quiere debate está transmitiendo
no reconocen ese Brasil que está siendo
presentado
en estos momentos por el otro Paulo aquí
en Brasil ha vivido un desastre absoluto
en los últimos cuatro años y eso hace
con claro el apoyo a bolsonador había
disminuido muchísimo en relación a 2018
salió de un apoyo muy importante y hoy
tiene algo alrededor del 30%. entonces
la gente está muy decepcionada con lo
que ha pasado en Brasil en estos últimos
Y eso de alguna manera transmite la idea
de que no hay una conexión lo que el
pueblo espera pues no es
buscado no se promueve por quien está en
el Palacio del plan alto y ahí sí me
parece que la memoria de Lula tiene un
peso enorme porque se identificaba más
esa relación en el 2006 en el 2007
cuando Brasil crecía muchísimo y los
indicadores sociales eran muy buenos en
efecto hubo problemas graves con el
gobierno Dilma en términos económicos la
política económica de Irma Fue muy mala
pero cuando Lula terminó el gobierno en
el 2010 pues Brasil vivía una situación
internacional incluso muy importante con
una proyección global que nunca ha
tenido y no ha podido tener Tampoco hoy
el purel rol pues se acuerda de eso la
gente que está votando en estos momentos
tiene ese recuerdo tiene esa memoria
entonces de alguna manera lo que empieza
en favor de Lula es la memoria
exactamente la idea de que podrá hacer
otra vez a partir del 1 de enero lo que
ya hice en el pasado y no será nada
fácil Yo quiero aquí
Añadir un punto importante que es la
absoluta y responsabilidad fiscal del
gobierno bolsonaro hay una bomba fiscal
que va a explotar ya seguramente a
partir del año que viene por este montón
de auxilios y ventajas que el gobierno
ha dado a la desesperada para intentar
aumentar su apoyo y que seguramente
alguien lo va a tener que pagar en el
futuro reducir impuestos
conceder un montón de auxilios a un
montón de gente tiene un precio y tiene
que ser de alguna manera pagado en el
futuro y no se sabe cómo se va a hacer
es decir hay una bomba fiscal que va a
ser terrible para quien gane las
elecciones el próximo domingo no
entonces las actuaciones delicada hoy y
lo seguirá siendo seguramente en los
próximos años mejor sobre la mesa
también para el señor moura el tema
fiscal que piensa usted al respecto de
esto que dice Paulo Velasco y le añado a
la pregunta Le adiciono también esas
dudas que ha dejado el presidente
bolsonaro en torno al desempeño del
sistema electoral un sistema electoral
que lo eligió a él como presidente Hace
unos años atrás y un sistema electoral
del cual es él está haciendo partícipe
en este momento al ser candidato y
aspirante a la reelección Cuál es la
necesidad de sembrar estas dudas entre
los ciudadanos y entre el sistema
político del desempeño y de la
institucionalidad brasileña
Brasil es muy buena
recuerdo o que ministro Pablo Guedes
economía a contrariado el mercado está
descansado lo que aconteció en la
economía brasileña fue problema de la
pandemia el tejan el cierre de la
economía
por parte de los gobernadores los
perfectos con apoyo de la cúpula del
judiciario ha causado problemas y el
gobierno brasilero tuvo uno dos millones
desempeños económicos en el mundo al
socorrer empleas empleos gente
este apartamiento del presidente de la
población no es lo que se ve a la calle
las imágenes están ahí el presidente por
primera vez izquierda enfrenta un
presidente Popular de derecha el
presidente bolsonar es amado por el
pueblo circula por todo el país al
interior inclusive corriendo riesgo de
seguridad personal porque se demasiado y
yo a texto que cuando las urnas cerraren
en el domingo las pesquisas y el clima
de opinión criado artificialmente por la
media
será desmentido así como esta falacia de
que hay crisis fiscal a vista hay
superávites
ha explicado este claramente cuánto la
cuestión del sistema electoral no es una
dura apenas del presidente bolsonaro
presidente bolsonaro levanta esta
cuestión de la transparencia del sistema
desde antes cuando era debutar cuando
era diputado había prometo de él El
Congreso brasileño Ya aprobó por dos o
tres veces un sistema más transparente
de control con con un comprobante de
Voto impreso y no es accesible para el
editor llevar para la casa más que
permite conferir verdura contradicción
entre lo que dicen la curación y
formatizada se puede conferir esta es la
situación y cerca de 35 a 40 por ciento
de la población brasilera
compartida esta duda Entonces no a Cómo
entendirse que la justicia que el
superior tribunal Federal que el supremo
tribunal Federal que tiene ya nueve
magistrados escolido por
gobiernos anteriores de oposición se
oponga
está garantizar un sistema mínimamente
transparente hay afirmaciones de que el
sistema de confiable Pero sabemos que
sistemas informatizados son vulnerables
claro
se ataca gobierno en el mundo entero
entonces lo que se quiere es simplemente
un sistema transparente pero este tema
en este momento de elección ha perdido
preeminencia claro no no está haciendo
la evidencia que tuvo en otros momentos
pero las bases del presidente bolsonaro
demanda esclarecimiento sobre ellos y el
presidente tiene conexión con el pueblo
tiene conexión con su base y sí señor
respondieron
Sí justamente quiero Añadir que el
tribunal electoral de Brasil ha
introducido cambios justamente en el
sistema de recuento de los votos todo
esto en aras de garantizar un proceso
transparente y para evitar posibilidades
de cualquier tipo de cuestionamiento Por
alguno de los candidatos y por algunos
de los de Los Seguidores de alguno de
los candidatos que esté participando no
solamente en las presidenciales sino
también en los otros procesos
electorales que va a haber paralelos
este mismo fin de semana vamos a ver ya
en la práctica cómo se van a desarrollar
esos nuevos parámetros y esos nuevos
cambios que impuesto el sistema el
tribunal electoral de Brasil
señor moura quería preguntarle entonces
para finalizar y por favor sea muy
puntual sobre esta necesidad que tiene
el presidente bolsonaro de de de generar
este esta duda justo en el proceso
electoral esto genera controversia y
esto se suma también la la lo que ha
denunciado o lo que ha anunciado
previamente de no reconocer un resultado
si no es un resultado favorable al
presidente bolsonaro esto ya siembra un
mal camino para este proceso electoral
no cree
el llamado de de fascista de autoritario
digitador de golpista Pero esto no se
comprueba en la práctica el presidente
nunca ha mandado a aprender periodista
fijar vehículos de empresas cerrar
vehículos de prensa no ha perseguido
él siempre depende libertad de
información y verdad de prensa a pesar
de los ataques cerrados que reciben y
como yo he dicho aquí al abertura del
programa Esta es una no es una elección
común por ejemplo sonaron no está
enfrentando Lula está enfrentando un
sistema que no quiere entregar el poder
la gente que siempre estuve mancomunada
controlando el poder de estar en Brasil
de una alianza con empresario corruptos
con políticos corruptos con la cúpulas
del sector judicial que indicada por
candidatos y oposición por ex
presidentes y hace parte de esta lucha
si el presidente Quisiera dar un golpe y
yo tenía hecho en 7 de septiembre de
2021 porque tiene lealtad de los jefes
militares y votó millones de personas a
la calle así como voto mucho más de
nuevo en este 7 de septiembre
es un demócrata al contrario el señor la
prensa brasilera internacional Ya vamos
llegando a la parte final del programa
El último bloque paso a preguntarle al
Señor Velasco sobre el otro candidato el
candidato el Lula da Silva justamente
cuando terminó en la presidencia contaba
con altos índices de popularidad entre
los brasileños pero luego vinieron estos
escándalos de corrupción su paso por
prisión
su enfermedad también que lo lo retiró
un poco de durante un tiempo de la vida
pública es muy distinto el Brasil al que
se está enfrentando Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva ahora a el Brasil que el gobernó a
principios de la década de los 2000 que
puede ofrecer Lula Más allá de su
experiencia como mandatario para para
hacer una presidencia diferente porque
el país está en un contexto diferente y
el contexto internacional es sumamente
diferente
pues no será nada fácil la verdad en el
caso de que efectivamente ganen las
elecciones tiene un reto enorme a partir
de enero porque el Brasil que va a
encontrar es mucho peor del Brasil que
encontró en 2003 en el 2003 Brasil vivió
en la actuación mucho más estable en
términos macroeconómicos veníamos de
casi 10 años del plan real el gobierno
Fernández ricardoso hizo un buen
gobierno y entregó un Brasil estable y
que era más previsible ahora la
situación económica es una asociación de
incertidumbre completa la bomba fiscal
está ahí y vamos puede explotar a
cualquier momento como ya comentado y
tiene un reto enorme también en términos
diplomáticos que es reconstruir la
pésima imagen de Brasil en los últimos
años que ha dejado la diplomacia del
gobierno bolsonaro Brasil se ha
transformado de un protagonista que ha
sido en los años 2000 de a un país
completamente irrelevante en la arena
internacional alguien vamos ignorado por
todos y acusado de cometer crímenes
graves por ejemplo en la agenda
ambiental es decir no tendrá la vida
nada fácil porque tiene que reconstruir
la política doméstica tiene que buscar
una unidad nacional que no va a ser
fácil no tiene que buscar un crecimiento
sostenible que no va a ser nada fácil y
tiene que reconstruir una imagen pésima
que tiene Brasil hoy día en el mundo es
decir va a encontrar un Brasil en una
situación muchísimo peor de la que
encontró en 2003 Ojalá tenga fuerzas
para cumplir ese objetivo y señor Maura
muy puntual por favor le pregunto ahora
por el candidato bolsonaro un candidato
que ya pues prácticamente está
terminando un primer mandato puede que
llegue a una segunda fase de una
presidencia un poco más prolongada qué
lecciones ha aprendido bolsonaro a lo
largo de estos años como presidente que
le puedan servir para mostrarse aún
mejor como presidente de Brasil habiendo
aprendido de estas críticas
internacionales por el tema Ambiental de
estas críticas que recibe por la forma
como se dirige a las mujeres y a las
minorías Como por ejemplo la comunidad
lgbti
mucho retórica de la media sobre estas
cuestiones Brasil esta noche situación
internacional
especialmente después de la pandemia
después de la de la guerra cuando
mantuvo posiciones por la paz entre
Rusia y Ucrania Brasil es el mayor
florecedor de alimento del mundo es un
Aliado estratégico del occidente en los
cambios que están aconteciendo de
transferencia de las cadenas de
distribución y producción de China para
países próximos y confiables del
occidente al contrario de La retórica de
que dice el otro Pablo y lo que dice la
prensa Brasil hoy es la novia más
decejada del baile de la fiesta no
entonces presidente ha madurecido si el
has elegido en condiciones excepcionales
por internet y ser también que cuatro
años en la presidencia de República lean
la madurecido y yo creo que tiene toda
condición de hacer muy bien sucedido
dado que las condiciones económicas al
contrario
el otro aristas son excepcionales para
Brasil crecer establemente por 10 años
con contratos firmados es no es retórica
de prensa es la vida sin embargo Brasil
sigue recibiendo muchas críticas a nivel
internacional por el tema ambiental
sobre todo por esa ampliación de la
frontera agrícola en zonas de la
amazonía señor Velasco él le preguntó
ahora por la importancia del voto de dos
sectores muy importantes de la sociedad
brasileña bastante particulares son los
votos de los evangélicos y los votos de
los jóvenes Qué tan importantes van a
hacer y qué tan cruciales van a y
definitorias van a ser para esta lección
los evangélicos tienen Mucho peso
político en Brasil es un grupo que ayudó
a muy claramente bolsonar o a ganar las
elecciones Hace cuatro años uno de los
retos de Luna en la campaña ha sido
acercarse a ese grupo e intentar
convencer desde que él puede también
representarles de alguna manera y que no
necesariamente la única opción para las
iglesias evangélicas es votar por el
sonar Entonces es un grupo importante es
un grupo muy influyente en la política
brasileña ha tenido un creciente en rol
dentro del parlamento brasileño por
ejemplo el número de diputados senadores
que están de alguna manera involucrados
con las iglesias evangélicas ha crecido
muchísimo es decir es un segmento muy
importante y puede tener un peso
definitivo y lo que se ha visto claro es
un intento de Lula vamos a ver el
domingo lo que pasa si tiene de alguna
manera algún hecho en eso pero un
intento de ampliar el apoyo de esos
grupos a su candidatura y los jóvenes
Pues claro es hay que reconocer que
entre los 16 los 18 años el botón es
obligatorio en Brasil entonces un número
muy de jóvenes se registró para votar en
estas elecciones lo hará por primera vez
va a encontrar un país muy dividido y
claro aunque no sean tan expresivos en
números absolutos pero pueden tener
algún impacto Sí al final del resultado
porque la posibilidad por ejemplo de una
victoria en primera vuelta en ese
definiría exactamente por un número muy
pequeño de votos y a lo mejor los
jóvenes pueden tener algún rol y algún
impacto importante en ese sentido en
grupos que pueden ser muy muy decisivos
Santiago me queda un minuto para
terminar el programa quiero que hagamos
las conclusiones y que me respondan Qué
puede suceder este domingo allí en
Brasil comienzo con el señor Maura qué
va a suceder va a haber segunda vuelta
en la que se enfrenten bolsonaro y Lula
da Silva o Lula o bolsonaro pasarán
directamente y ganarán la presidencia en
esta primera ronda de la votación como
lo vio usted
primero necesaria defender algo nervioso
brasileño que está situada en las
regiones azul centro centro este sudeste
y norte de Brasil y es un cuadro negocio
ambientalmente consciente y que preserva
el ambiente yo creo que va a haber
segunda ronda
hay una creación artificial de un clima
de opinión forzado por perquistas pagas
por bancos por grandes vehículos de
medias que apoyan Lula en el sentido de
hacer presión sobre los electores para
liquidar la elección a la primera ronda
lo que mis análisis de datos no
confirman yo creo que habrá sorpresa
como Yahoo en varias otras elecciones
presidenciales y regionales de
desmoralización de estos institutos de
pesquillas aquí en su mayoría
tendrán que ser investigados Habrá
segunda ronda la elección ahí concuerdo
es una edición nacerrada El vencedor
vencerá Por poco si no hay vencedor
antes contado y su opinión para el
cierre señor Velasco
poesía todavía hay muchas dudas sobre la
posibilidad de célula ganar en primera
vuelta yo también no lo veo nada fácil
yo creo que las encuestas pueden tener
algún alguna diferencia sobre lo que es
la realidad Porque los bolsonaristas en
efecto no suelen responder a las
encuestas no confían las encuestas
siguen mucho la opinión del presidente
en el que dice que las encuestas y los
sondeos no sirven para nada entonces
muchos de ellos Simplemente no responden
no responden bien a los sondeos Y eso
puede hacer con que los resultados el
domingo sean un poco distintos de lo que
estamos viendo Entonces no veo muy fácil
que lo la consiga ganar en primera
vuelta sería una estupenda sorpresa si
lo consiguiera porque evitaríamos ahí
tres semanas muy duras por delante en
ella todo se decidiría tendríamos más
tiempo para pensar en el futuro de
Brasil y para que Brasil vuelva a ser el
actor importante que fue en los años
2000 pues la opinión de Pablo Velasco y
de Paulo moura desde Brasil les
agradezco por haber hecho este análisis
para la audiencia de France 24 en el
resto de América Latina les agradezco
por haber compartido su análisis con
nosotros es todo por hoy el nombre del
equipo técnico del programa Les
agradecemos su sintonía la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Pedro
Ruiz y la producción de invitados a
cargo de Tania Herrera Pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios y sus preguntas
a través de las redes sociales sigan con
nosotros
[Música]